hallo lieber Serdar ich duze dich denn
ich kann deinen Namen nicht aussprechen
du bist mir aufgefallen durch deine
Bühnenprogramme die ich auch sehr gut
finde und als ich gehört habe dass du
ein Album machst war ich natürlich
erstmal skeptisch das Album hat mich
sehr überzeugt ich bin zufrieden damit
es ist es gehört zu dem Kreis der Musik
die ich gerne gekauft habe und auch
immer noch höre allerdings habe ich zu
den Album eine Frage und es ist eine
rote Frage ist dein Ego wirklich so
klein dass du dich inhaltlich bei
einigen die dann auf das Niveau von
Bushido und Konsorten herablassen
musstest und Texte über den
Geschlechtsverkehr mit asiatischen
Frauen den Geschlechtsverkehr mit
behaarten Frauen und den Verzehr von
vikalien schreiben musstest ich bedanke
mich für deine Antwort wünsche dir noch
viel Spaß im Interview und ich wünsche
vor allem dir Christoph dass du es ja da
irgendwie in den Griff bekommst
na das ist eine suggestiefrage ist dein
Ego wirklich so klein also warum ist
mein Ego klein wenn ich über
Geschlechtsverkehr mit asiatischen
Frauen schreibe das diskriminiert die
asiatischen Frauen er als mein Ego ich
habe da keinen Maßstab gehabt ich habe
nicht gesagt Bushido macht dass ich
mache das nicht sondern ein Teil der
Songs auf dem Album sind ironisch ich
sag's noch mal ein Teil der Songs auf
dem Album sind ironisch und Sushi Muschi
das ist der Track auf den er sich hier
bezieht oder frisst meine Scheiße sind
Titel die auch durchaus ironisch gemeint
sind und deswegen habe ich da keine
Berührungsängste gehabt schon gar nicht
mit Bushido weil ich glaube der meint
ernst du musst aber Ironie auch noch mal
erklären Ironie muss ich auch noch
erklären weil sie wirklich nett und im
Fernsehen es ist wirklich problematisch
woran erkenne ich Ironie ja das ist so
eine Frage woran erkenne ich Ironie
woran erkenne ich
woran erkenne ich überhaupt etwas daran
dass ich mir Gedanken darüber mache wer
das sagt wie es gemeint sein könnte und
was es für ein Sinn macht das ist so
gemeint ist weißt du wenn wenn ich als
Türke beispielsweise es gibt ein Video
von mir die hate night da rede ich
schlecht über Türken es ist naheliegend
dass ein Türke der über Türken schlecht
redet ist nicht ganz so meinen kann ja
ich sag aber auch am Ende noch dazu
abgesehen davon dass unter der Show
steht die satirische Show im Internet ja
dass ich das nicht so meinen könnte also
mehr Hilfestellung kannst du nicht
leisten irgendwann musste dann auch die
dummen so dumm sein lassen wie sie sind
und
anerkennen dass man die klüger die
klugen noch nicht klüger machen kann